all of the archaeological and
anthropological evidence from prehistory
and current day hunter-gatherer
societies shows that we evolved to live
in small groups of 4050 people maybe a
hundred hundred fifty people those were
the typical living sizes based on
encampments that have been found and of
course people living in those conditions
today the size of our brains seems to be
correlated to groups of about that size
when compared to other primate species
clearly we live in a modern society and
we organize ourselves in much larger
groups but our wiring our evolutionary
wiring seems to be back dated to a
period of time some tens of thousands of
years ago when we lived a the existence
of hunter-gatherers in a very harsh
environment our evolutionary design has
a lot of implications for how we live in
modern society and of course for how we
conduct warfare a platoon is around 40
or 50 soldiers not by coincidence that's
around the size of a typical
hunter-gatherer group in our
evolutionary past one of the things that
soldiers find when they're deployed in
combat or even at a rear base is that
they very naturally fall into a kind of
communal existence with their platoon
mates they're sleeping
shoulder-to-shoulder their take eating
meals together doing missions and
patrols together they're doing
everything together you're never out of
sight of another person and you
basically live for the group there is no
individual survival outside of a group
survival in our evolutionary past and
often in combat as well because we're
wired for that because we evolved for
that it feels very very good when you
experience that and I've experienced it
as a civilian reporter in a platoon
it feels instantly right the only
analogy I can think of is holding a baby
in your arms for the first time it just
feels like oh my god this is exactly
what I'm supposed to be doing this is
this is right and and that kind of
communal existence feels deeply deeply
correct and natural in the same way and
so when soldiers come back from
deployment often often they missed the
war but what they really miss I believe
is that that communal connection not so
much the combat and the killing of
course they're not Psychopaths they're
just like the rest of us but they do
miss that communal connection because in
modern society it's pretty much gone and
they don't really notice that until they
return to it
one thing that interested me in
researching my book tribe was the high
rates of PTSD post-traumatic stress
disorder in the US military and an
estimates vary but they ranged as high
as around 20% and much higher
percentages than that claiming
disability from it in the Israeli
military
by contrast the rate is as low as 1%
it's it's a hard PTSD is a hard thing to
measure and that's why there's some
variability but it's as low as 1% it's
way lower than in the US and I wanted to
know why we're there roughly equivalent
militaries modern societies what is the
difference and Israeli psychologists
that I spoke with pointed to a couple of
things one was that that the the wars
that Israel has fought in the last
couple of generations have been like
right on their doorstep the Yom Kippur
War of 1973 saw Israeli soldiers
fighting literally on the outskirts of
their own villages fighting an invading
army and and the psychological damage
that comes from fighting in the in that
kind of circumstances is is greatly
lessened compared to traveling thousands
and thousands of miles to fight a war
that doesn't de see doesn't seem to bear
any relation to your home to your
country it's a it's it's a it's a
distant affair that doesn't maybe
doesn't seem necessary sometimes the
other difference between Israel and
America is that Israel has mandatory
military service roughly half of Israeli
citizens serve in the in the military so
if you're a soldier and you saw combat
in Lebanon or whatever when you come
home you're coming home to a community
where an enormous number of people were
also in the military so there really
isn't a transition from military to
civilian life it's all blended there's a
lot of civilian life in the military
spurious and vice-versa so the so the
question is during a very fractured time
in American society the gap between rich
and poor is widening we live often live
in racially segregated communities
there's a real really ugly betrayal at
content to political discourse these
days there are politicians talking with
real contempt about their president
segments of the population when you have
a country that's in such a state of
disrepair what can you do to bring it
together one possibility is mandatory
national service with a military option
personally I think it's immoral that for
someone to fight a war they don't
believe in but mandatory national
service would not just be enacted during
wartime it would be continual and it
would allow young people to contribute
to us all contribute to this country
without having to carry a gun you can do
it in many other positive ways and I
think you would do enormous good not
just for the young people themselves but
also for for this country as a whole
this country doesn't require anything of
its citizens when you're when you don't
have to invest in something you don't
value it one of the advantages of
mandatory national service is is that it
enforces an investment of a year or two
by a young person in the collective good
of this country and when you do that you
create value it takes all the races all
the social classes everything all the
educational levels and puts them in a
big pot and stirs them up together and
gives everyone the experience of
investing in the collective good the
downside of course is that we're in a
very sort of anti-government state of
mind right now in this country and that
there might be
objections to it one of the reasons we
might be in an anti-government state of
mind is precisely because no one in this
country is required to spend any time at
all contributing to the collective good
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy it's a
feedback loop how do you break that
feedback loop well you break
by changing the law it will take
courageous politicians who are willing
to buck a national sentiment to do
something good for the country
at some point politicians have to put
their country before their careers and
simply vote for what's right in the long
term